one of the last remaining Witnesses of
the JFK assassination says he is
rethinking the entire indeed incident of
that was going on for the first time
former secret service agent who was
protecting Kennedy that day told the New
York Times the quote I'm beginning to
doubt myself now I begin to wonder about
what really happened of course this
comes as JFK's nephew Robert F Kennedy
Jr is now seeking the Democratic
nomination for the presidency but the
so-called Democrats not are not acting
very Democratic so if RFK Jr feels like
he is not getting a fair shake from the
Democrats will he run third party he
joins us now with more
um Let me let me first ask you about the
secret service agent the name of the
guy's name is Paul Landis he talked
about the Magic Bullet Magic Bullet to
me was absurd from day one uh never
never to me it never had any credibility
he was there even on put himself on
record at the time and mentioned that he
made a mistake in his placement of the
bullet in in that room where your uncle
was after he was shot my question to you
is does should this now open a
full-fledged investigation
yeah well uh yeah I mean the interesting
thing about this development
is not uh really his Revelation because
the this information has been out there
and the information you know the
overwhelming information that there was
more than one shooter involved and that
there were multiple people
involved has been recognized by the
American people 70 of Americans don't
believe the warning report but more
importantly
when Congress investigated
reinvestigated the Warren Commission
evidence and and was looking at much
more evidence in 1979 the house select
assassinations committee they came to
the conclusion and this was the
conclusion official conclusion the
report that John Kennedy was killed by a
conspiracy
the majority of that house staff
believed that it was the CIA behind that
conspiracy the important thing that's
happened now is finally the New York
Times the Orthodoxy is starting to
crumble
the New York Times which has been the
major
bash and the champion of the Warren
committee law report long after it was
discredited by a million different
sources the other thing that's important
now Sean is yeah I think that they ought
to have a real investigation of
of what happened our genuine
investigation
um but I all then looks at all the
evidence the millions of pages of
documents
that are now available but more
importantly the last 5 000 pages of
documents that the CIA will not release
it's breaking the law now they're
supposed to release those documents by
2017. President Trump promised to
release them which was his duty and then
he did it we don't know why President
Biden promised to release them and then
Eden we don't know why
among those documents the most
interesting things that people want to
know about is Bill Harvey's the Miami
station Chief who almost certainly was
directly involved in the assassination
is travel records on that day and I
think most of the scholars
who are looking at this issue that that
is the principle
piece of interest that they're that they
want to know about that we believe that
the CIA is concealing I want to see all
those documents I agree with you they
should be released to the public let me
uh your campaign manager Dennis kucinich
actually said the following in a letter
to the DNC that they created a class
unfortunately a pledge delegates call
Party leaders elected officials
essentially the same as super delegates
due to the amount of control the party
exercises over elected officials
basically saying you can't get a fair
shake that the deck is stacked against
you Joe Biden already pulled out of Iowa
pulled out of New Hampshire because he
thinks he'd do better starting in South
Carolina
you know if you're not going to get a
fair shot with the Democratic party and
you're not getting even a fair shot in
the mainstream media you're very
complimentary of fox we appreciate it
that we're being fair and we give you a
voice my question to you is why stay
with the Democratic party would you
consider third party would you consider
the No Labels party
or any party
well right now I'm still we're still
we're still arguing with the DNC and
trying to get them to hold actually a
fair election as you pointed out they
have disenfranchised now
the all of the voters essentially in
Iowa New Hampshire the states in which
President Biden ran forth the last time
around so they're punishing the states
that did not vote for President Biden
the last time by basically
disenfranchising the voters making it
so that if you live in New Hampshire you
cannot vote for anybody but President
Biden this time around
they're they're trying to do something
else which I think is much more alarming
which is they're trying to pass a role
they're debating right now to pass rule
and it's almost certain to pass
that voters in Georgia will be
disenfranchised if they vote for any of
the if they if they vote for me or for
Marianne Williamson well let me ask you
that would you consider another will you
consider running on another party ticket
well I you know right now I'm focused on
trying to run as a Democrat this is my
home this is the place I grew up I don't
seem very friendly to you I'm hoping to
make the Democratic party work when Sean
Hannity is nicer to you than they are
you got a problem
you would agree with that
you know I did not treat you fairly why
why stay with them well if they're not
going to treat you fairly why
well I'm hoping that they will I'm
hoping that they will at least allow a
fair vote in the states outside of New
Hampshire and Iowa we'll know this week
all right and we'll bring you back next
week and ask you the same question how's
that
we appreciate you being here
all right Robert F Kennedy junior thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else